سافر أكثر من ألف طالب
للمشاركة في التحدي العالمي الأول
وحدث الروبوتات السنوي الذي
يجذب المراهقين من ما يقرب من 200
دولة ، إنها مسابقة كبيرة للروبوتات
حيث يأتي فريق من
كل دول العالم تقريبًا
للتنافس جنبًا إلى جنب وفشل  روبوت
يمضي قدمًا في الملعب يلعب لعبة
مع الروبوت ، لذا فهي تشبه كرة القدم تقريبًا
مع وجود منافسة روبوت شرسة ،
لكن شغف التكنولوجيا
هو جوهر هذا الحدث ، فأنا أحب
هاتفي الذي أحصل عليه كل يوم
وبدون  أي
هندسة تقنية علمية ورياضيات لا يمكنك استخدامها في
هاتفك ، فلا يوجد إنترنت ولا سيارات
ولا وسائل نقل عام ولا شيء ، وإذا كنت
تستمتع فقط باستخدام التكنولوجيا في
مشاهدة التلفزيون ومشاهدة Netflix ، فأنت بحاجة إلى
الحصول على بعض التقدير للعلوم
والتكنولوجيا والهندسة في أغلب
الأحيان  وراء هذا التجمع العالمي ، يوجد
دين كامين مخترع في
عشاق التكنولوجيا والهدف هو إظهار
قوة التكنولوجيا للأطفال في جميع أنحاء العالم
logy إذا فهموا ذلك واستخدموه
بشكل صحيح يمكن أن يساعد في حل
أكبر مشاكل العالم والرسالة
آمنة
ما أحبه في الأول عالميًا
لدرجة أن التركيز على
القضايا البيئية وهذا شيء أنا متحمس جدًا له
وأنا  أعتقد أن جميع
القضايا البيئية التي لدينا في
عالمنا سيتم حلها عن طريق
التكنولوجيا وسيتم حلها من
قبل جميع الأطفال الموجودين في هذه الغرفة
وأعتقد أن التكنولوجيا ستكون
الحل الأكثر
جدوى لكل شيء
بدءًا من  الاقتصاد في
السياسة أعتقد أنه يمكن حل كل مشكلة
بمساعدة
الهندسة والروبوتات في
التكنولوجيا المستقبلية يمكن أن تكون أداة
قوية تستخدم من أجل الخير وإذا تعلموا
كيفية التواصل والتعاون بشكل أفضل من
آبائهم وأجدادهم
لأجيالهم  يمكن أن تتوقف مع
الجروح التي تسببها الذات بناءً على
الاختلافات المتصورة وإدراك أنهم جميعًا
متشابهون في الغالب ويمكنهم جميعًا التحدث
بنفس اللغة  باستخدام الرياضيات
والفيزياء والهندسة ، يمكنهم جميعًا
جعل العالم مكانًا أفضل
لأنفسهم وبالنسبة لنا سواء كانت دروسًا في
العمل الجماعي أو إيجاد حلول تقنية خضراء
للمستقبل ،
هناك شيء واحد واضح أن هؤلاء الأطفال
يأخذون أكثر من ميداليتين فقط في  هذه
المنافسة هي الأفضل في CNN
[موسيقى].